today I'm going to tell you about
neutrinos and dark matter and
specifically at uh for about experiments
that are going on at this house pole so
as Kurt mentioned and I am an assistant
professor
is it going okay
so I'm an assistant professor at here
Yale University
and I study neutrinos and dark matter I
do experiments to study neutrinos and
dark matter so why should we care about
Nutri neutrinos and dark matter well
they could constitute a huge fraction of
the universe and they play a very
important role in in How the Universe
became came to be and also how it's
evolving over time
um and by understanding better how they
interact with each other and with
ordinary matter we can understand better
How the Universe uh Works
um so
um I first became interested in this
subject about 10 years ago
so that was about the time when I earned
my PhD and I actually got my PhD doing
Atomic physics what's traditionally
known as atomic physics so what I was
doing was I was using lasers to
manipulate atoms I was using lasers to
push atoms around and then I would
collect them in a little little ball and
then once they were trapped in this in
this ball so I can use lasers to slow
down the atoms and I could use the
lasers to collect these atoms and once
they were collected they would stay
there for a long time a lot longer than
you know typically atoms are washing
around all around you know in this room
um and everywhere but once you collect
them you can do very precise
measurements on these atoms and so
that's what that's what I was trying to
do uh for my for my PhD that's what I
did for my vhd
um so and then I finished my PhD and I
was trying to figure out what I wanted
to do with my my life after that and
then an opportunity came up where I
could use the same technique of laser
Cooling and trapping and applied to
study properties of neutrinos and how
neutrinos interact with ordinary matter
okay so so that was uh that opportunity
I was in Berkeley California
so I went there to do what's called
what's known as a postdoc job so uh when
you're uh when you finish your post
um finish your PhD as a graduate student
you might get further training as a
scientist kind of like an internship if
you're going to medical school and
that's called uh that's called postdoc
in academic academic world so I did
postdoc in Berkeley studying neutrinos
and then after that
okay so neutrinos
are
everywhere and they're actually produced
often in
produced when radioactive atoms like
uranium thorium or even potassium that's
in your in your body they can undergo
radioactive decay Okay so the nucleus
breaks apart and when this happens
neutrinos come come shooting out as well
okay so it also they also come out from
the Sun so the sun is powered by protons
fusing together to to form helium and
then helium atoms fuse together to
become Boron and then nitrogen oxygen I
forgot carbon nitrogen oxygen and so on
and so in all of these processes
neutrinos are are being produced and so
you know it plays a huge role in in how
how you know how Stars
Burn okay so so I wanted to study
neutrinos using laser trapping
techniques
and so that's that's what I did for my
postdoc work now
um you know you may have heard that
neutrinos are interact they interact
only rarely with ordinary matter and
that they're very difficult to to detect
so what we do is to to rather to than to
to catch them directly what we do is to
study how they interact with with the
environment so they might
glance at a regular nucleus and then the
nucleus gets a little kick and then we
can try to see how you know how much
kick the nucleus got or it might glance
off of electrons and then we know how to
how to look at that as well so that's
how we look at neutrinos that are
ordinary you know the very difficult to
detect but by using their interaction
with ordinary matter we can study the
properties of neutrinos
okay so with the laser trapping and
Cooling and dropping I was looking at
this byproduct of of nuclear Decay so
that the experiments that I want to tell
you today are called Ice Cube and dmis
so dmis is an offshoot of Ice Cube so
these experiments also study neutrinos
and dark matter and I'll tell you about
that and both of these are located at
the South Pole
um let's see what else can I tell you
um okay so Ice Cube is uh we call it a
neutrino telescope so not only do we
study the properties of the neutrinos
themselves because these particles are
produced in the inner workings of the
Sun or you know Stars also when um when
stars collapse into supernovae active
Galactic nuclei these processes we think
should also be producing neutrinos and
so Ice Ice Cube's goal is to try to
detect these neutrinos coming from this
very energetic processes that are going
on in in the universe
okay
um so uh yeah so I got involved in ice
cube when I moved as Kurt said with my
husband to Wisconsin so that was in 2006
and I worked on Ice Cube and in the
meantime I also started a new project
called dmis to to try to look for dark
matter at the South Pole and so
somewhere along the the way I became a
professor so that was about in 2010 and
then last summer
we moved our family moved to to
Connecticut to New Haven here to Yale
University
um so I'm continuing this research on
neutrinos and dark matter
and
yeah I'm looking forward to to seeing
more of you
um in you know as as we build more at
Yale
um so I mentioned that that we just
moved to Connecticut but actually I'm
not new to Connecticut I grew up in
Connecticut so I went to middle school
and in high school and so I'm I'm really
happy to be back here and I I've missed
it for the last 20 years but I'm very
glad to be back
okay
um so uh let's uh let's get on to
physics enough about me
um so okay so you see my slice here
so this is a picture of the South Pole
and in particular
this is uh the Ice Cube lab so the bulk
of the detector for Ice Cube is actually
buried two and a half kilometers so over
a mile under the ice that you see here
and all you can see are the the cables
that come up uh you don't even see the
cables but they're going up through into
those Towers across the the tunnel and
into the into the laboratory there and
the laboratory is full of computers
where we process the data coming from
all the optical sensors that are
underneath the ice
and then once the data gets processed
they they get put on satellite the data
comes over satellite and to to Northern
America North America
okay so the the the question uh that we
uh we try to answer uh that we're trying
to address in physics
um is
um is essentially uh what is matter uh
so what are we what are we made of and
what are the the rules or the laws that
govern how this matter behaves okay so
um so you know what we like to do to
study these uh what we're made of and
how how what the rules are
what we like to do is to we we like to
break up
um you know we made up into little
smaller and smaller chunks and then we
we study how they they behave so I found
actually on this on this on the on the
web so I'm just gonna show it to you so
it's called
um let's see if I can
uh get it
to the center
it's called the scale of the universe
okay so uh here we are on the human
scale and the unit of length that we
like to use in physics and this is an
international unit it's called meter one
meter is about this long okay a yard or
three feet about that
um so I'm about 1.5 meters tall
um you know that's a slightly taller uh
gentleman there
um okay so we're gonna go zoom in to uh
to see
what happens when we go into that okay
so I don't know who Russell is but
whoever made this animation I presumably
is using teapot shuru you zoom in longer
you got a quail and right smaller
smaller now you're talking about a
millimeter so that's about the size of
say a pixel on your computer screen
might amoeba okay so we're gonna go even
smaller uh so here's a human egg
smallest thing visible to the naked
inside
it's as small as your eyes can see
um and then let's keep zooming in so
here's a Mist droplet
nucleus of a cell okay so now we're
starting to break apart uh the the
ordinary things that we can see every
day okay so you go zoom in zoom in
chromosome right and now you're a micron
okay micrometer 10 to the minus 6 meters
so now you're talking about viruses okay
let's keep going you zoom in more and
more DNA okay let's zoom in more and
here's here is nanometer 10 to the minus
9 meters okay so this you're talking
about a fairly large atom so atom is
made of
nucleus and a cloud of electrons around
it okay
um so let's zoom in further
so you got water molecule carbon atoms
angstrom tenth of a nanometer so at
angstrom you're talking about hydrogen
atoms helium atoms so these are some of
the smallest atoms or these are the
smallest atoms that are around okay so
let's go break things up either even
further okay so now you have picometer
10 to the minus 12 meter
okay let's keep going so now we get to
the nucleus Okay so we've Stripped Away
the electron cloud and at this scale
we're starting to see things like a big
nuclei like uh uranium
here's chlorine let's keep going helium
nucleus proton protons and neutrons so
these are on the scale of 10 to the
minus 15 meters okay so this is starting
to get to the level where we are what we
call particle physics and fundamental
physics Nuclear Physics is at this scale
where we've taken atoms apart and you're
left with protons and neutrons and you
know for a long time we thought this was
as small as we could go so
Marie Curie right look looked at
uranium nucleus
and she was studying how these nuclei
break apart okay so you could she knew
that these things can break apart and
then you go toward protons
and and neutrons
and zoom and more
so you can go even more and then now we
know that the protons and neutrons can
break up even further into what we call
a quarks so we've never been able to
observe these by themselves so but
collectively we can break up protons and
neutrons and we can see evidence of of
these uh these particles quarks
okay we can actually go even further
okay so strange cork uh other different
types of quarks and now we're getting
into the neutrino regime 10 to the minus
21 so if you ever wanted to know what
the prefix is for 10 to the minus 21
it's zero meter zepto meter
never used it okay here's more corks
let's keep zooming in zooming in zooming
in
okay so there's really not much in this
region
and let's just go all the way in and
then this is the smallest scale that we
ever think about is the plank length and
so if you ever heard about string theory
and so on this is the the length scale
that we're talking about so and then in
the corner you see 10 to the minus 35
meters okay
so now we study this this uh this very
small scale let's see what happens if we
go all the way out to the to the to the
big scale right so I'm going to go back
out to the human scale
okay
and you can you can go and look this up
online it comes with a really really
cool music and so I'm not playing that
but
um okay so human scale is coming
up okay so okay so let's go zoom out so
sunflowers a little bit bigger than
human beings uh elephants dinosaurs
trees bigger dinosaurs bigger trees
airplanes
okay
um bigger structures that humans have
built
um Eiffel Tower the pyramids
Hoover Dam
right and then other structures so this
is on the order of a kilometer
10 to the three meters a kilometers uh
two-thirds of a mile
okay so you've got Hoover Dam uh Half
Dome
uh let's keep zooming out
um so Central Park okay and big comments
uh or small comments I should say Mount
Everest
um distance of a marathon if any of you
are are marathon runners
um you can you can go clear across Rhode
Island if you do that
all right so let's keep zooming out so
countries uh and moons
moons of planets okay
so this is the scale when 400 years ago
when Galileo first started using
telescopes to look up into the sky
right so he could see some of these
moons
um he could see some details of the
planets
it might be bigger by now but I'm not
sure
okay so people are laughing about the
Minecraft okay so um okay the sun okay
and bigger planetary objects so you've
got the Polaris
and here's the scale distance from Earth
to Sun okay so let's keep looking out
further
okay so and here's uh What uh the the
distance so the light day is the
distance light can travel uh in one day
so you can see it's it's quite a bit of
distance that light can travel but it
does take one day for light to cover
this distance and that's comparable to
some of the longest distances that
humans have ever covered so Voyager 1
was a satellite that was sent out to the
universe and that's that took I think 10
20 years or something to get out there
okay
all right so let's keep going out
all right so some of the bigger objects
out in the sky that we can see so uh
nebula nebulae nebul nebulibe
okay
um and
a bigger objects nebuli and then now
you're starting to get into clusters of
of these things so here's a dwarf Galaxy
the magellanic cloud
um so these are some of the objects that
are closest to the to our galaxy
um but a little bit outside
okay
so and here's
uh let's see
okay so let's see so here are some of
the galaxies that you see
and you just keep zooming out okay so
here's the local group right so galactic
center plus the Lush modular Cloud
install and so on is called the the
local group some of our neighbors Virgo
cluster
um and then now we're at
Yoda meter Yoda meter okay 10 to the 24
meters
okay so we can zoom out even more
and you keep going and
um here's uh some of the Sloan digital
survey Sky survey has seen you know can
see out to to this distances Giga
parsecs
okay and then uh Hubble Telescope can
see uh out to to that distance there
okay
um and then you get to the edge of the
observable universe
okay so I've taken you from the smallest
things that we ever think about to the
biggest thing that we ever talk about
and by studying the smallest things that
we can ever think about we can uh track
the history of what is going on in the
biggest Scale of the Universe pretty
cool right
all right so let's get back to the
today's slideshow
okay
so
um so what now that we've broken up
um what we think about to to the
smallest things that we can think about
we've identified four different forces
that rule all of this matter so uh
gravity so we all know that if I jump
I'm gonna come back down to to the
ground
um second one is the electromagnetic
force so especially in the winter you
notice this a lot right so you shuffle
your feet around on carpet you touch the
light you get a nice lap all of this
right we know how to control
electromagnetic force uh the the best
um so you know all the lights we've seen
here electricity
all the um all the electronics computers
all of this is using the electromagnetic
force
there are two that you may not have
heard about very much and those govern
how the nuclei are put together so the
strong force
binds the neutrons and the protons
together inside the nucleus and then the
weak Force is is the force that helps it
break apart and that's the force that
neutrinos can interact with ordinary
matter with and dark matter we think
should be able to interact with ordinary
matter using using the weak Force okay
so we I think about the weak force a lot
and then we try to simplify this even
more so it's been successful we've
successfully combined the
electromagnetic and the the weak force
and we can pretty much do that with the
strong force but nobody's ever been able
to
um to do that with with gravity okay so
gravity is sticking out on its own and
we don't really know how to reconcile
how to think of it as one one rule of
all these four forces but this is
something that a lot of people are
trying to do
okay so we're going to focus on uh
gravity uh and the weak force and then
our detectors use
electromagnetic force quite a bit
okay so
um so I gave you a picture of these
different particles that we think about
and then the four different particles
but of course there are a lot of
mysteries out there that we don't
understand so one of them are the cosmic
rays so in 1912 Victor Hess
realized and so here's Victor Hess
boarding a a balloon so he saw where
these particles these um these events in
his detector and he was curious as to
what where they were coming from so
there were these particles that he could
see and he thought they were coming up
from the Earth but
um to to prove that it is really
actually coming out from the earth what
he did was to he to put the detector on
a balloon right and he flew up high and
and if it really is coming from from the
earth then the number of these particles
should should decrease as he goes up so
what he found was that as he went up
these the number of part these particles
increased and uh the field of cosmic ray
physics was born and so what we see is
that as you look up into the sky there
are these charged particles that are
flying around everywhere and then this
is a plot this is how you just read the
spot so this is a the energy of these
particles versus the number of these
particles going through a particular
area
and then so there are lots of them at
lower energies as you look higher
energies there are many of them and then
so there are these discharged particles
and for a long time people didn't really
understand where they were coming from
and so they're having many many studies
to to look for these uh and the modern
day once detectors are installed up in a
satellite or we also can do ground-based
detectors where we look up into the sky
look for these cosmic rays coming into
the atmosphere they Decay and then we
try to to reconstruct what it was they
came from so it looks like these
particles are mostly coming from things
like supernovae so these these
supernovae or these things can
accelerate charged particles and this is
what we see and so one of Ice Cube ice
cubes mission
is to try to
complete the picture of how cosmic rays
are produced so that the the processes
that produce these charged particles
should also produce neutrinos and so Ice
Cube wants to see these these neutrinos
that are produced in the same way as as
Comet cosmic rays
okay and then dark matter
okay so in 1933 France Fritz Wiki he was
looking up at through telescope and what
he noticed was that the mass of the
galaxies within what's called coma
cluster
seemed to be there didn't seem to be
enough mass to to
um to look at the to to produce the
motion that that they were that they
were moving at so I brought a little
demo of mine
so here's an apple you can't talk about
gravity without apples right
so what he was noticing was that
as
so the way the the planets move is is
with gravity and I can't really produce
gravity for you so I'm just going to use
this and so think of my hand as say a
big sun and then here's a planet and
then I'm going to swing this around okay
so this is how you produce circular
motion and as I swing this I can feel
right pull on my hand produced by the
planet the little planet that I'm
swinging
all right
so I can do this at a constant speed but
if I swing faster I have to hold on to
this bag harder otherwise one of you is
going to get clunked by an apple in the
head
all right so this is this is what he
found is that
um that the velocity of the uh the
objects that he sees up in the sky is
moving a lot faster than if the Sun or
you know what was in the middle of this
uh circular motion uh it just it just
seemed to be a lot massive so bigger
objects exert bigger gravity and there
just seem to be a lot more mass out
there
okay so this study continued into the
into the 70s
um so uh Vera Reuben and co-workers
found uh that rotation of galaxies uh
are flat so uh you have galaxies and
it's rotating around the center and it's
that it's not this two-point
um you know so it's not just two bodies
that we're talking about about all the
all the mass that's between you know my
hand and and Outer Perimeter and she she
also found that there seems to be a lot
more mass in between than what you could
see with optical telescopes and so she
said what you see in Aspire Galaxy is
not what you get
okay so since then there have been more
evidence for dark matter
um so one of the coolest things you can
do is uh be um you can actually bend
light using gravity
so you may have heard about how light
behaves uh like
um
like particle and if you put a massive
object in between you and whatever it is
that you're trying to see or distance
star and if there is a mass in front of
it you can actually see the light
bending
so you can see
in this picture
in black and white is that if if you can
see some of this streaking all right
features and so this is due to
um light being bent around
massive object that exerts gravity but
we can't actually see using these
telescopes
then the bullet cluster is is kind of an
interesting example
and so this is a false color rendering
of where we think the dark matter is
that's in blue and where we think the
hot gas out there so that's in pink
so there are these two clumps of of
matter passing by each other
okay and then the Dark Matter uh the
rendering is essentially done by things
like gravitational lensing so we try to
see where the dark matter is and then
these two objects collided with each
other and because dark matter doesn't
interact very much with each other it
just kind of went straight past each
other but the hot gas that is in this in
these two clouds uh actually got you
know they interacted with each other and
they they were they were getting dragged
and slowed slowed down by each other and
so this is the this is another example
of how why we think there's Dark Matter
out there
okay
um so
um this is uh the picture that we have
when we have
compiled all of the information that we
have from optical telescope and mostly
actually all from uh gravity right we
can see dark matter with with gravity
and then by simulation
we can we think the dark matter is
distributed more or less evenly but
there's these you know
filaments and little clumps and so on
but the clumps you know everywhere you
look it kind of looks like this
and then there are these uh images that
we can take
and then if you've heard about Cosmic
microwave background again the
um the dark matter can distort our how
the
microwave gets to us from the furthest
reach of the sky and so from that we can
see dark matter and then if we go if we
zoom in zoom into to look at the Galaxy
this is kind of what it looks like and
so here's our Milky Way and then there's
this Halo of dark matter that surrounds
it
okay so that's the picture of of dark
matter that we have today
now I want to tell you a little bit
about neutrinos
okay so neutrinos they're pretty much
everywhere and they're produced in the
big bank so when when the universe first
started there were these neutrinos and
then these neutrinos they were about 300
and 330 neutrinos per square square
centimeters square centimeter is like
you know the tip of my pinky
and then there were only 0.5 protons in
that volume okay
so when we look out there are different
neutrinos coming from all sorts of
sources so supernovies produce neutrinos
there are high energy Cosmic neutrinos
that we would like to see so that's
that's you know that's the story of Ice
Cube
the sun produces neutrinos and then when
cosmic rays hit the atmosphere the
Earth's atmosphere they can break up
into smaller chunks and that process
also produces neutrinos
and then the Earth itself produces
neutrinos so the Earth is warm the core
of the earth is warm and that's powered
by radioactive decay of things like
uranium thorium
and so those those radioactive decays
producing neutrinos and then there are
also man-made neutrinos so particle
accelerators can make them and power
nuclear reactors also make neutrinos
okay so uh in in all there are some 30
trillion neutrinos go through your body
every second okay and these are mostly
the cosmic neutrinos
right 30 trillion neutrinos but most
just go right through we don't ever feel
them
all right so this is uh the picture of
the neutrinos we had in the late 90s
okay until 1998. so we thought there
were three different kinds of neutrinos
and this is similar to the the quarks
that we talked about in the beginning
and so there were the new um the
electrons muons and power neutrinos and
that's associated with electrons beons
and Talons so those those are also
Elementary particles
and we thought so and then there were
three flowers flavors and then we we um
we only had some limit of some idea of
how big how small how
so we had an idea of that they might
have some Mass
but mostly uh the description of the
universe consisted of a massless
neutrino
okay so what happened in 1998
um is that uh and uh through say 2003 or
these um series of experiments called
super Cameo candid
and then accelerator based
experiments also in Japan
snow this is up in Canada and cameland
so these experiments
um
found that actually neutrinos indeed
have mass and that actually has some
implication as to to right how that
universe is is made up
so just to give you a scale of these
experiments so here's a boat with
a little boat with three people
so it's a detector that is filled with
water a tank cylindrical tank filled
with water and then these three people
are are inspecting the licensors that
will detect the neutrinos at once this
detector is running
snow is about eight meters in diameter
so it's I think as big as this this room
okay so these are Big detectors to be
able to uh to
detect these very weekly interacting
particles
okay
so these are so we talked about ordinary
matter we talked about dark matter and
then there was even yet another surprise
in this time around 1998 and also in
2003. and this is what we found so by
looking so supernovies are actually
pretty useful instruments they they this
is you know similarities are formed by
stars collapsing on their own and it
they produce a lot of light okay so
here's a picture of one of these
observations from I think uh from the
Hubble telescope so here's a supernova
going off you see that little Dot and
there's actually as much light coming
out of that little dot as an entire
galaxy that is nearby okay so it
produces a lot of light and it produces
a lot of light that is about the same
every time
okay
so it's a good good calibration Source
it's a good light source where we can
say okay if we see this light at some
distance I should see so much so much
light coming from the Supernova if it's
further I should see less amount of
light
so it tells us the distance
um of of these objects the brightness
tells us the objects and then from sorry
Cosmic microwave background we saw
actually
that the furthest edges of the universe
that we can see is actually accelerating
so the picture that we have of the
universe evolving is that it started out
with a with a big band and then the
universe expanded okay so it was in the
beginning it was slowly expanding and
then at some point it started it started
the expansion started accelerating so
what is that what does that mean
so I'm going to take out my trusted
Apple again
right so in in normal circumstances if I
throw out this up into the air what
would happen
right so it would go up see if I can do
this without dropping it right it would
go up and it comes back down
what these experiments were observing
was that if you if I were to throw up
this apple in the air it would actually
start accelerating so it would speed up
and keep going
okay so that just seems weird
right so this is uh now what we call
Dark Energy whatever energy whatever
force it is that's making this apple
fly away from where we are
okay so we don't have a very good idea
really of of what dark energy is we've
gave we've given it name right and we
can see the effect it has on on the
expansion of the universe but there's a
lot of experiments that are trying to to
figure out what this is okay so that's
dark energy
so you put all of this together and this
is the picture of the universe that we
have okay so if you've heard of e is
equal to m c squared we we think of
matter and energy to be uh um you know
of one and the same and so if you break
up
um what is in the universe the heavy
elements like iron and so on makes up
only 0.03 percent of the universe
right
and then neutrinos which we thought were
so abundant is only 0.3 percent of the
total energy of the universe
let's go a little a little bigger Stars
0.5 percent
okay so Stars there's as much stars
nearly you know and as as neutrinos
nearly
it's not amazing so there's this
neutrinos streaming through
bulk of what we know that's out there is
actually hydrogen and helium that only
makes up four percent
of the total energy density of the
universe
the rest is this dark matter right stuff
that is making my making the planets go
faster than what we how then we think
they should and dark energy
so there's so much of the universe that
we really don't know how to to think
about
Okay so we've been talking about how
difficult it is to detect neutrinos from
dark matter
well um they play um they do play a
major role and you know the upside is
that there's a lot of them right so even
though they interact very little there's
a lot of them the catch is that they
interact so little with our Norm it's
it's actually really difficult to detect
so uh here's kind of a cartoon picture
to show you exactly how how elusive they
are they can go through a light year
okay the distance that light can travel
in one year
so that's that's much further than you
know to the Sun
so that that it can go through a light
year of lead without ever interacting uh
with with with lead
all right so uh to to detect neutrinos
we want to build big and quiet so you
know if you want to hear something very
uh faint right you want you want every
noise to be quite to be gone so same
thing with detectors you want every
other noise event to be gone so and then
you want to build it big so that you
have a chance of catching them
okay
so where can we
um
so I'm going to skip this slide a little
bit so if we look at the the
close by
um our galaxy
um and uh then uh I describe that we
think there's this Halo of dark matter
okay so how do we detect a dark matter
so the way we do it is
um there's this Halo of dark matter and
then the sun is rotating around like out
center of the Galaxy
and the Sun is rotating around the
center of the Galaxy at 200 kilometers
per second that's 450 000 miles per hour
imagine that okay and then the Earth is
going along for a ride and it's actually
rotating around the Sun at 67
000 miles per hour okay so and then it
also rotates once a day right and if
you're sitting at the equator you're on
top of that you're rotating at a
thousand miles per hour
great roller coaster right
Merry-Go-Round okay so the way we look
for dark matter is we can look for these
occasional cases where it just you know
kicks uh knocks a nuclei or whatever we
know uh you know how to detect
we can also look for this annual
modulation so part of the year we should
see more interaction part of the year we
should see less and then we can also
look for daily modulation
in that signal
okay
so there are several ideas of what this
dark matter could be and then we call
these weekly interacting massive
particles this weekly is that weak
interaction force that we talked about
okay and then we know they have mass
okay and and we know we think they could
be particles so this is pretty much all
we know about dark matter that we see
out there okay so how we're gonna look
for this
um so I'm going to show you uh now that
we've talked about these particles that
we're trying to detect I want to talk a
little bit about the Ice Cube and and
dmis
okay so this is what South Pole looks
like when you get to uh when you fly in
so
to get to the South Pole this this is
what you do you you fly on a commercial
airplane to Christchurch New Zealand
and there you get outfitted with you
know your red parkas that you might have
seen
um or you know and just warm warm
clothes so that you don't freeze when
you get there
and then you fly on a military airplane
uh to make Myrtle so the edge of um
it's hard to edge of Antarctica
and then you fly you take another flight
to get to the South Pole and then we fly
into that South Pole you fly to this
Runway
and then you see the uh thank you you
see the South Pole station
okay South Bowl station here and this is
the footprint of the Ice Cube so it's a
kilometer wide
two and a half kilometers deep into the
into the ice
okay so I want to have a little time to
to show you what the detectors looks
like and and also some pictures from the
South Pole so I'm gonna skip a few
slides from now so what we do is we
drilled uh holes into the ice and then
we instrument every hole with 60 of
these Optical sensors okay so this uh
this thing can actually detect light
and so each of these is about this big
okay and 60 of these are in each of
these holes
okay
so this is how we detect neutrinos so
neutrinos come in from some Source it
doesn't matter and then they interact
with the ice and then they get converted
to for example muons okay so once they
have been converted into muons these are
regular charged particles and we know
how to detect them
actually when charged particles go
through medium that's not vacuum they
can travel faster than light okay and
they uh so that's nothing special they
can travel faster so when they do that
they produce this shock wave and we call
this chain called flight
okay so this shock wave it's like Sonic
Boom when when airplanes go faster than
speed of sound you get this boom okay so
we we look at look for this boom of
light and then these Optical sensors can
see where they were and then by uh
picking out which uh which light sensor
saw light we can point back to where
this neutrinos
neutrino must have come from
okay so it's a pretty big collaboration
it's about 300 physicists from all over
the world
okay so many are in the US a lot many
are in Sweden in in Germany there's one
institution in in Japan
and few in
Australia and New Zealand
all right so this is what our Event
Viewer looks like so that it doesn't
actually look like this but as particle
come in this is how we look at our
events so the the color of the light
tells you uh the time uh in the time
window that the optical sensors saw some
light so red is early and blue is late
uh yeah and then the size of the bubble
tells you how much light saw
okay so all we see essentially are these
and then from the information we get
here we draw these lines that point back
to where these might have come from
okay so to drill these two and a half
kilometers into the eyes this is what we
do so the first top bit of the eyes is
actually pretty mushy snowy stuff so we
use heater coils to go down there
and then once you break through that we
switch the type of drill and then we use
a hot water jet to go into to go down to
two and a half kilometers into the ice
okay
and then once that hole is drilled and
this drill is is extracted from the
water
and then we start instrumenting uh the
um the ice with these Optical modules
so the the wall the holes are full of
water and then we dunk these sensors in
and then we let the water freeze around
our sensors and so once once the light
sensors are in there we can actually
extract them again
okay
so here's a team of the The Ice Drillers
can anybody find me in this picture
yeah so they let me they let me hang out
with them and the way you can tell a
physicist from a driller
I don't know can anybody tell
okay my jacket is very clean
so these these uh men and women worked
so hard to drill these these holes and
then we get to come in and you know drop
in our sensors and so on but it's really
a fantastic bunch to work with
and here's a picture of of uh scientists
after the completion of Ice Cube so Ice
Cube actually took a long time to
complete and the time that we spent on
the ice is about seven years
and uh you know the the South Pole is
only accessible for four months out of
the year and you know every four months
of those years we were back every every
year to build this so we we made a
detector uh here's here's me again
okay
it's very exciting
okay so this is a picture of this DMI
detector
all right so
I'm gonna skip these things
okay so uh because Ice Cube was being
constructed we also wanted to attach a
couple of other instruments here and so
this one is is an instrument that is
looking for this annual modulation
signature that we can expect from Dark
Matter so there's one experiment that
claims that I've seen this modulation
and a lot of people have tried to to
check their answers
um you know some people say well I don't
really believe you
um the the onion you know there's so
many things that change annually like
the seasons the temperature you know
maybe one of these things could be
affecting how your instrument works and
so what we what we are trying what we
want to do with this is to check uh you
know their their extra extraordinary
claim right they've they've detected
dark matter and so what we want to do is
to repeat this experiment at the South
Pole where the seasons are different
than in the Northern Hemisphere and so
this is a prototype that went in with
Ice Cube and we're in the process of
building the the bigger Next Generation
experiment now
Okay so
uh it's a smaller group of people
so here's some pictures of from the
construction of the instrument so I
mentioned that we want to keep these
detectors as quiet as possible so these
were built using um
using a clean room like environment
and here are some pictures from the
South Pole okay so you thought you were
going to the most remote place on Earth
and this is this is what you see so to
drill these these these holes it
actually takes quite a bit of
infrastructure to do that and I
mentioned it's a hot water drill you
have to heat up all of all of this water
you can see all this piping sending
water all around
okay so let's do some pictures
okay so living at the South Pole has
gotten
um
actually any questions on on the science
part of it so I'm going to show a few
few pictures from the south pole but if
you have questions from about the
science I can answer them
yeah
yeah so we see that right they they're
um they're out there but we don't know
how they interact with each other we
don't know how they interact with
ordinary matter
um so we have a picture of what it what
what what the universe looks like today
and we have a picture of you know we can
go back in time by looking at distant
light uh we have we have picture of what
how the university evolved but you know
to go beyond
um how
um
how it might evolve in the future you
know it might be useful to know what
what they are it also constitutes 25 of
the universe why wouldn't you want to
know what they are yeah
yeah
anti-matter
um well so
um
we know what we know is that
um when we look out there we hardly see
any of it out there so that's a whole
another question a whole another set of
physics
um but that's that is a really big
question that people are trying to
answer so you know we there's matter and
antimatter uh yeah matter and antimatter
if they collide with each other they
shouldn't highlight you can also create
matter and antimatter but from
pure energy can you know you can pop
matter and antimatter out so whatever
Big Bang was you know it should have
produced the same number of matter in
antimatter but what we see out there is
only matter and so there's some process
that made that had an imbalance between
these processes and we don't know why
that is and that's actually one of the
biggest research that's going on
today
yeah
so in the solar system what percentage
of the solar system is
in the Solar so I think it's it's pretty
much about that this 25
yeah that's
if I think it's if it's so prevalent
um so um right so the
um so the sun is pretty close to the
edge so the effect so the effect of the
the dark matter is more obvious as you
go further out from the center of the
Galaxy
so if you remember the curve from their
Reuben the difference between only
having matter and dark matter is is just
a lot more pronounced further out you go
and so if you go further out in the
Galaxy the objects that are rotating
around the the center of the Galaxy are
moving way faster than they should
so we haven't detected anything locally
that's right so that's what we're trying
to do yeah yeah
so
much
I mean the you know the Earth so we're
essentially swimming in in dark matter
and we're streaming through it in the
universe yeah
uh
it could but we don't know how yet
yeah
how do you make neutrinos
um well
uh
everything that's sitting in this room
the little dust particles has just the
tiny a part in a million is has a little
bit um is uranium particle or your body
has lots of potassium in it and apart in
tentative
part in ten one in ten thousand is a is
a radioactive isotope of potassium and
so when the when these uh atoms Decay
they actually emit neutrinos
and they also come out from the Sun like
when the protons
fuse together things like that yeah
um so in in a medium uh so you start out
with muons
traveling you know has some energy
energy and then in a medium as long as
they have enough energy they can travel
just that fast
probably not yeah so I talked about you
know combining the weak and the
electromagnetic force but that only
occurs at a very very different energy
than our everyday energy that we talk
about yeah
so it's mostly uh curiosity but you know
they they it matters
um how how much energy is coming out of
the sun right and it matters uh you know
and so there are some applications that
people have come up with it's like like
can you monitor uh Power of nuclear
reactors using that but mostly it's it's
a curiosity
we created
how can dark matter be created that's a
really good question so it was created
in the Big Bang
and uh yeah and we also tried to create
this in things like places like um the
Large Hadron Collider at CERN and so we
try to create it see if we can create it
in a way that we understand and maybe
those dark matter particles that we
create is is the dark matter of
particles that we see out there
Arena can finish because I know some
people have to leave for other events
yeah
yeah go ahead
lightning storms uh no
okay
all right so these are really good
questions so so you know here's some
pictures that I pulled together so last
year was the 100th anniversary of people
getting to the South Pole ever
um and a lot has changed it's gotten a
lot more comfortable to get there I
could actually you know leave uh and
come back within a few weeks right from
home just to home back to home
um and you know 100 years ago you had to
take essentially two years of trip to to
go there and some people never some
people never came back
um so right so you know you took a ship
and you had to wait for the oceans to
fall out before you get there and you
spend the whole winter and then you know
after the the spring comes and then you
could start you know traversing across
um and so now you know we just take an
airplane to get there
um the reason to go to the South Pole is
still science driven okay so the first
um
trips were scientific Expeditions so if
you read about Shackleton or amundsen at
least the excuse was that we were going
to do science in Antarctica and uh at
least the excuse now is still to do
science okay and and it's really amazing
science that we can do
uh transportation's improved quite a bit
right so you could take dog dog sled
people sled and we essentially fly in
there accommodations has gotten a lot
also uh come more comfortable
um so you know you you only took what
you could carry back then and now uh we
yeah we we take what we can carry but on
airplanes right
um
teamwork is still a big part of this it
is still a very remote location if you
leave the station you know you do have
to be cognizant of the fact that it is
very cold outside and the altitude is
actually quite high so you do have to be
careful about altitude as well so
teamwork is is an important part you
know we go there we're building this big
experiment and camaraderie that comes
out of you know getting doing making
working toward one single goal you know
that that is you know I I really enjoy
working with this team
I would say the food has also improved
quite a bit so here's a picture of the
cafeteria that exists now and actually
flying food there is the most expensive
part of of food so the the cost of food
is dominated by you know the the expense
it takes to get the food there so it
really doesn't matter if you're shipping
chicken or tofu or Lobster or a steak
and so you actually get fed fed quite a
pretty pretty well there but also
working out in the cold you burn a lot
of calories and so you do need food so
you know a lot of improvements over the
years but a lot of things are still the
same and I think the you know the human
drive to to know more to understand
what's going on in the universe you know
that's still that's still what's driving
our desire to go to places like like the
South Pole so thanks
thank you